Peter Wexler, thank you
for being on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Oh, I'm doing great, Michael.
Thanks very much.
Where are you calling from right now?
I'm calling from my covid pandemic
office hideout in downtown Palo Alto.
Wonderful.
So, we're neighbors.
I'm right here on Forest Avenue at Hippo.
But it's really really great to have you.
And I'm really excited
to talk to you about teamwork.
You've been a part of numerous teams
in various positions.
Both on the end of the company
as VP of Engineering.
And really internally
and seeing through acquisitions,
joining huge companies.
You mentioned Siemens
of over 400,000 people internationally.
And on the other side also,
being a board member on various companies.
It sounds like
a different type of teamwork.
I'd love to learn about both experiences.
And I'd love to explore with you
over these next 19 minutes or so
what makes a team strong.
What makes the team, perhaps,
weaker than the others.
So, take me along your journey, Peter.
Let's start from the beginning.
Walk me a little bit about
where you come from,
and your insight into teamwork.
Let's see.
Undergraduate electrical engineering.
I was always interested in that stuff
when I was a kid.
Science, engineering,
ham radio, all that stuff.
And actually through that,
I had a strong interest
in biology as well.
So, I ended up getting a graduate degree
in biomedical engineering.
Imaging of the retina,
and a lot of image processing,
which was great.
And I worked in that field.
I actually worked for an Israeli company
called Elscint in the early days,
which was a pioneer
in nuclear medicine and ultrasound.
But for a whole variety of reasons,
I ended up in the networking field
very early on.
Before there was the Web.
Before there was anything else.
And I've actually spent
a fair time of my career
in the networking space,
both for large companies,
but also, with some
very early stage companies.
From zero, from maybe 15 people.
And for the whole issue of teamwork,
one of the ones I like to focus on
is Juniper Networks.
So, Juniper Networks,
which is one of the major players
with the infrastructure
that's in the Internet,
I was the first VP of engineering.
I started maybe
when there were 15 or 17 people.
Oh, wow. Okay.
And there are a number of reasons why,
and when we ran the company,
we ultimately had
675 people in engineering.
And we were half a billion dollars
by the time I moved on.
But a lot of lessons that I learned there
from the folks I worked with.
And so, the first thing was
when you're building a team,
in addition to the key technical skills
that you're looking for,
you have to look at the
how people play together.
And how is an individual going to be
as part of a team.
Because it's not about, these days,
one individual can't do the whole thing.
Especially when you're doing
complex things.
The thing I'd mention to you, Michael,
I like to say,
any given day is the best thing
you've ever done in your life,
or the worst thing you've ever done
in your life.
And I like to say, the average
just needs to be above zero.
Right.
And then it's a good thing.
So, one of the things
that we did at Juniper was,
we were have very extensive process
during the interview.
And it wasn't so much,
yeah, there were technical reviews
and that sort of thing.
But it was really,
a group of folks trying to understand
the personality of the individual
and how they would fit within the team.
Which is not to say you want everybody
to look the same
because people looked way different.
There are a lot of different people.
But it's like how would they play
as part of the team.
Because when challenges happen,
you need to be able to solve them
in a really constructive way.
And on the other hand,
when wonderful things happen,
there's nobody better to celebrate with
than folks who are focused
on the same goal.
And so, at one level,
in terms of building a company,
that's teamwork.
You mentioned boards.
And that's a lesson
that I actually learned the hard way.
There was a well-funded company
that I was asked to join.
It was maybe about 20 people.
I came in to help sort out engineering.
And it had the reputation
of the individuals on the board
was all stellar, but unfortunately,
too many egos in the room.
Folks did not play well together.
And again,
when there were some tough times
and some tough decisions had to be made,
the team was incapable
of making out decisions.
So, its a group of board members
that are each individually are stellar,
but coming in together don't seem to find
the unity and the harmony
to come up with good results.
Actually this reminds me
of a beautiful quote
that [--],
also from Jay Venturers,
mentioned to me just a few days ago
in our call, he said,
"If you want to be a good leader,
learn to check your ego at the door."
And I just loved that imagery
of checking the ego at the door
and walking in and he referred that
as to the whole J-Venture's mantra.
That we come in
and we have one hundred people
in the room looking at deals
and every person feels that,
while they can contribute,
they also have so much to learn
from everybody else.
I think that's exactly right.
The other piece is,
the other thing is,
if you're hiring the best people you can,
what you find is
your hiring type A people.
Now, it's like an arranged marriage.
There's no reason it should work.
You're slamming all these people together.
Everybody has success.
Everybody's got an ego.
It won't work.
So, your job as a leader
is to basically keep the thing
from going off the rails, till you get to
whatever milestone is important.
Now, having said that,
everybody who's going to come in
is not going to be even keeled.
And that's not what you want.
So, the trick is, I always say
I give you more latitude
in terms of your enthusiasm.
Based upon how much
of a contributor you are
and how you help the rest of the team.
So, every so often
people have a meltdown or whatever else.
But if they're good contributors
and they're working well, we understand.
And frankly, teams understand that,
Even the small team, everybody knows
how much everybody is contributing.
And everybody gives everybody a break
if people are contributing.
So, you're not going to get people
who are uniform and smiley and wonderful.
Everybody is going to be very intense
because they believe.
But, like Andy Grove used to say,
You decide and commit.
Which is, we can be passionate
about our discussions.
And we got to get it on the table.
But once we decide on the direction,
we got to move forward.
Because if we keep going,
even if it's small steps,
moving forward is key.
And so, how do you facilitate
that moving forward mantra,
especially as you're working
on these various companies?
All of them are critical infrastructure.
A lot of these are, perhaps,
longer term projects
that you don't celebrate every day
and you don't see progression every day.
So, as a team leader,
how can I continue to motivate a team,
and to continue that mindset
of moving forward and making decisions
where keeping everybody passionate,
if we're looking at long term
commitments and not short term goals?
So, one of the things that is important
is transparency, right?
Which doesn't mean
everything's on the table.
But being transparent because,
particularly when things
get a little bit of tough,
that's when conspiracy theories start.
I don't know if it's engineers,
or it's the same with biologists,
or whatever,
but if something's not going right
or they see that you're worried,
absolutely the worst thing
that's possible would be dreamt up, right?
And certainly not the case.
So, keep a check.
I forget who said it was,
The leader has a long tail.
So, you better be careful
how you swing that thing.
So, you need to be transparent
about what's going on.
And a lot of times,
there's a lot of moving parts
in these businesses.
And people don't always have a background
or an understanding or the experience.
And you need to be able to translate
and explain to folks what the context is.
We're going out.
We're raising money.
It's taking a longer time.
We actually had to raise
the second round of funding
for a company we started
during the recession.
Took twice as long that it was before.
Everybody got a little bit worried.
But you need to explain what's going on.
Don't leave things in mystery.
And it's just all about
helping people feel comfortable.
And you do it one on one.
Or you do it with a group.
And hiding things is not good.
Being transparent where you can,
and helping to put things in context
is important.
And that's, frankly,
if you have a good board for a company.
Bringing in a board member or two
who has a very good perspective
and having that person
sit with the company,
so, you're not the only person.
It's not like you're just
melding platitudes.
You're bringing in some other folks
who've got some perspective
who can help folks.
So, Peter, it sounds like
a lot of this foundation
is built upon respect, open mindedness,
along with this idea
of contributing to the team
and being a team player.
Talk to me a little bit
about this idea of respect.
How do you facilitate respect?
And then the next question would be
open mindedness within a team.
Because at the end,
the team is not just
performance based team
where you just you check off goals.
What you're talking about here
is that every person
needs to be contributing.
You need to come in unison
and complement each other.
And to me, it sounds that
a fundamental aspect of this
is the respect, right?
It's important.
And there's respect
in different dimensions, right?
Technical respect,
human respect, etc, etc.
Culture starts from the top.
And actually, we see this
in some companies in Silicon Valley
that have been written about.
They say that, it's like the fish
it rots from the head.
So, not my words, but others.
But it's true.
So, it's the environment
that you establish from the beginning.
And also, it's how you treat.
There are going to be people who,
while they may be great contributors
and be required to be around
for a certain period of time,
as the company grows,
it just may not be a good fit.
And frankly, you need to deal with those
and take action.
Because if you don't,
it's everybody recognizes
that you're not taking action
and you tolerate that behavior.
So, you've got to set the culture
from the beginning.
It's how you behave.
How you expect the team to behave.
When things go off the rails,
how you deal with them.
So, that's crisis management.
When things go off the rails,
how do you deal with them.
Are there personal experiences
that you've had, or any key moments
that you've observed where you saw
either people come on top,
or not succeed through these crisis?
I have had situations where things
have been brought to a head
because of certain individuals.
And so, if a particular individual
is problematic in a number
of different dimensions,
not so much because they're not technical,
but because it's their behavior
and how they create dysfunction
throughout the group.
So, I spent a lot of time
walking through parking lots with people.
As groups grew,
I started to ask myself,
"What do you contribute
to this technically?"
Because I felt more like
I was being a psychologist
or psychiatrist.
That's hilarious.
The office is open.
People come in, shut the door.
The next guy comes and shuts the door.
So, and too many times
walking around the parking lot.
And with some of that one on one,
you could smooth it.
But it gets to a point where you can't.
The hope is that you,
it's particularly tough with small teams
because everybody's critical.
But when you start to see this,
or get wind of this,
then you need to start
a long term strategy of saying,
"I think in the long run,
this person is not going to work out."
What am I going to do?
Because at some point
this person's going to have to go.
And how do I prepare other
folks to take on things.
How do I bring other people in.
And then, you ultimately
need to take action.
Now, having said that, most of the cases
don't involve ejecting a person, right?
It involves working with people
individually, one on one,
about how they can grow
and be more effective.
They usually don't want
to be a bad person.
They, a lot of times,
somebody will have experience
in a previous company
an style of behavior
that worked well for them.
Right.
And it's a matter of helping them grow
and learn that there are other ways
to get things done.
And in many cases, actually this works.
It's just, bad behavior that maybe,
especially if somebody
hasn't worked for 20 years, right?
If they're younger,
they brought bad behavior
from somewhere else.
So, maybe a little bit of mentoring
with myself or somebody else,
and give them some perspective
on how they might be able
to accomplish things
a little bit differently.
So, given the everything
we've talked about here, as I approach
my own leadership positions down the line,
and now I get to be a part of
a wonderful team here at Hippo
and at J-Ventures,
and I get to experience
really incredible people
and incredible mentorship,
both from a bottom up and top down.
But as I continue along my path
and become
a technical team leader myself,
or potentially a CEO down the line,
what are the core things
that I need to keep in mind
as I'm growing the team
and as I'm creating this family
that is going to work with me
on bringing a product to life?
So, I think just in general,
I'm asking you hard questions.
Well, so you're,
the value of the answer
is equivalent to the amount of time
that I put into thinking about.
So, number one,
I think just intellectual curiosity
and curiosity in general
is a trait that's important to have.
And the other thing is,
they used to call it at HP,
management by walking around.
Which is you want to be in touch
at all levels of an organization.
As organizations grow,
sometimes people are in touch with,
say, one level below them.
But you need to really understand
what's going on with the organization.
And you need to have many touch points
within the organization.
So, you really understand
what's going on with the organization.
You need to respect the role
of other leaders
and not go around them.
But try to work with them
to help them be more effective.
Because if you want to grow as a leader
and you want to scale
within an organization,
you can't do everything yourself.
So, how do you empower
and grow other leaders around you, right?
As you said, check the ego at the door.
It's not about you.
Trust me, if the company is successful
and you're a leader in the company,
it's going to reflect quite well on you.
So, you don't need to be the star.
And I think that's been the case with me.
I'm not the star in any of the ventures
that I've been part of, for the most part.
But you know what?
The success of the ventures
that I have been successful in
has served me extremely well in my career.
So, those are just a few things
that off the top of my head.
Wonderful.
Peter, what are you up to now?
What really excites you these days
whether it's with investments,
or the industry or the ecosystem?
What do you get hyped about?
What do I get hyped about?
So, there are a whole range of companies
that I'm working with.
Some more actively.
Some more passively.
I'm obviously involved with J-Ventures,
which is actually a wonderful group.
It's just, it' a really great group.
But there are a number of things
in the machine learning space
as applied to some really tough problems,
whether it's in health care,
drug discovery,
or other problems in the industry.
And so, I'm frankly doing
a massive amount of learning
from a lot of other folks
who are really passionate
in some of these spaces.
And again, working with you,
groups of young folks,
I mean, just the energy is great.
Some of us, if you've done
a few early stage companies,
you understand how hard it is.
But if you're young
and you haven't worked with that many,
you don't realize how hard it is.
So, everybody's got great energy.
So, but there are some things
in that space that are actually
really really exciting.
And then, so, you're coming in
and you're and you're getting exposed
to all these different companies,
are involved in them,
both in an advisory role, board seats.
And why specifically, machine learning
for solving difficult problems?
I mean, there's so many
different things that could happen.
Is this a recent passion
that you're developing?
Or is this something
that you've grown over the years?
30 years ago,
there was something called Lisp,
which was the first step at AI
back in times
when I was actually working for Siemens
in an industrial automation.
And you could see back then
the ultimate value of some of this.
But unfortunately,
our computer did not scale
to really address the problem.
And it's only recently
that we have some architectures
that are able to deal with things
like complex neural networks
and other things like that.
That you can now start to do things
like self-driving vehicles
or re-command your systems
or other sorts of things.
So, it's something that I've always,
or I remember, when I was in Boston,
I met with some of the folks at MIT
who were the early folks
in machine learning in AI.
And again, it was interesting.
But something stick
in the back of your head realizing that
it isn't going anywhere for a while.
So, just the fact that,
the technology exists now
they actually do some of these things.
It's interesting.
Having said that, unfortunately,
my interests are very broad.
So, I have some involvement,
a little bit of involvement in biotech
and in a few other places.
So, it's a curse of having broad interests
and a lot of curiosity.
And that's the problem.
I love it. I love it.
And I definitely,
I aspire to be exactly that.
To have that curiosity
and to go both in-depth
into certain fields.
But go agnostic and others
and be able to be open minded
and get exposed
to all these different opportunities.
Peter, before we go,
I want to thank you again
for your generosity
and for the inspiration.
I've learned so much
through this conversation.
But before we go,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself
or any of your partners in board seats
or companies would describe Peter Wexler.
The hardest question of all.
I think I've been an effective leader,
and have been in terms of growing teams
and growing teams rapidly.
I think I've been an effective leader.
I think that I am
a very even keeled individual.
Other than maybe, once a quarter,
I don't explode.
I'm just generally,
so, I don't freak out
when shit hits the fan.
And whatever else.
And maybe, just, insanely curious.
I was just about to say
that is the third word.
Because that resonates very very well
through this conversation.
Peter, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
This was wonderful.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Oh, thanks, Michael.
And best to you.
And I'm sure I'll see you
at a meeting of J-Ventures sometimes.
100%. Thank you. Take care.
Take care, Michael. Be well.